let X be a random variable and let G be
a function we know that if G is linear
then the expected value of the function
is the same as that linear function of
the expected value on the other hand we
know that when G is nonlinear in general
these two quantities will not be related
but there is a special case in which we
can establish some relation between
these two quantities in the form of an
inequality
this is Jensen's inequality which were
going to develop Jensen's inequality
applies to the special case where G is a
convex function I'm going to define more
precisely what it means to be convex
shortly but in terms of a picture it's a
function that has a shape of this kind
so it tends to curve upwards so let us
look at a simple example suppose that X
is a random variable that can take two
values with equal probability so these
two values have both probability 1/2 and
this is our function G of X since they
take the two values with equal
probability the expected value is going
to be in the middle so this here is the
expected value of x and in particular
this value here is going to be G of the
expected value of X now the random
variable G of X will take this value
with probability 1/2 and it's going to
take that value with probability 1/2
what is the average of G of X the
expected value of G of X is going to be
1/2 of this value plus 1/2 of this value
which you can find as follows if you
draw a straight line it's going to be
this much so this quantity here is the
expected value of G of X
and we see that in this example the
expected value of G of X is above the
value of G evaluated at the expected
value of X so this is what Jensen's
inequality says but for a more general
distribution for the random variable X
let us now step back and define more
precisely what it means for a function
to be convex the most general definition
is the following if I take any two
points x and y and I take some number P
between 0 & 1 so in that case the number
PX plus 1 minus py is a weighted average
of x and y so it's somewhere in the
middle and if I look at the value of my
function at that particular point so
this value here corresponds to this this
is less than or equal to the weighted
average of the values of G of X and G of
Y so this is G of X this is G of Y this
value here is the weighted average of
the two values so this quantity here is
P times G of X which is this value plus
1 minus P G of Y convexity means that
this value is below that value or in
other words whenever I take two points
on this curve and join them by a segment
then the function lies underneath that
segment this is one possible definition
now in terms of a picture we see that a
convex function tends to curve
words this means that the derivative or
the slope of the function keeps
increasing an increasing slope means
that the second derivative of that
function is non-negative and that could
be an alternative definition of
convexity it turns out that if you have
a function that's twice differentiable
these two definitions are equivalent on
the other hand the first definition is a
little more general because it also
applies to functions that are not smooth
so for example the function absolute
value of x is a convex one but it's not
differentiable at 0 finally there's
another way of defining convexity and it
is the following property again for
differentiable functions what it says is
the following if I fix a certain point C
let's say to use the same diagram let's
say that this is C this value here is
going to be G of C I look at the
derivative of that function and take
this quantity which is the derivative
times how far I am going this quantity
here is the first order Taylor series
approximation of my function so it
corresponds to this black line what this
condition says is that the function lies
on top of that tangent line to my a
function it is not difficult to show
that this condition non negative second
derivatives implies this condition what
you do is that you write down a
second-order Taylor approximation of
your function G and then because the
second-order term is going to be
non-negative because of that condition
you're going to get an inequality in
this form but in any case this
inequality is pretty intuitive and we
could take this one just
as our definition of convexity that is a
function is convex if it has the
property that whenever I draw a tangent
to my curve the function lies on top of
this linear function okay so now let's
move back to probability suppose that G
is convex this is true for every X so in
particular if I have my random variable
capital X no matter what my random
variable is we're going to get this kind
of inequality
no matter what and here what I left
blank is C now C is a number this is
true for any number so in particular is
true if I uses my number the expected
value of X
so we have this inequality that's true
now in terms of random variables no
matter what capital X happens to be this
will be valid and now let us take
expectations of both sides what we
obtain is that the expected value of G
of X is larger than now this is a number
so the expected value of that number is
the number itself plus the expected
value of this term this quantity is a
number the expected value of X minus the
expected value of X is equal to 0 and we
have established this particular fact
which is true for any convex function so
this is Jensen's inequality let us apply
it to some examples let's consider the
function G which is the quadratic
function clearly this is a convex
function it has this kind of shape and
the second derivative of this function
is positive that's another way of
verifying it Jensen's inequality is
going to tell us something about the
expected value of x squared now for this
expectation we already know that this is
equal to the variance of X plus the
square of the expected value and since
the variance is always non-negative we
obtain this inequality this is
consistent with Jensen's inequality
Jensen's inequality tells us that G of G
of X with G the quadratic function is
larger than or equal to the square that
is G of the expected value so for the
case of the square function Jensen's
inequality did not tell us anything that
we didn't know but it's nice to confirm
that it is consistent but we could use
Jensen's inequality in another setting
where the answer might not be as obvious
for example take
the function X to the fourth this is
also a convex function and Jensen's
inequality is going to tell us that the
fourth power of the expected value is
less than or equal to the expected value
of x to the fourth another case of a
convex function is the negative
logarithm remember that the logarithmic
function has a shape of this kind which
curves the opposite way so it's called
the concave function but if you take the
negative of this function then you're
going to get something that is convex so
by applying Jensen's inequality to this
setting what we obtain is that G which
is minus log of the expected value of x
is less than or equal to the expected
value of minus log X and then we can
remove the minus signs from both sides
and that is going to reverse the
inequality and we will obtain that the
logarithm of the expected value of x is
larger than or equal to the expected
value of log X so in this case for the
logarithmic function the Equality goes
in the opposite direction the reason is
that the logarithmic function is a
concave function not a convex one and by
arguing similar to this example a
concave function is the negative of a
convex function and for concave
functions Jensen's inequality still
holds but the inequality goes the
opposite way Jensen's inequality turns
out to be quite useful in many cases we
want to say
thing about the expected value of G of X
and Jensen's inequality allows us to do
that